unique lines classic design this is the
Bristol for one one made in the early
70s this car has been completely rebuilt
and it will cost you as much as a new
Porsche it's just over a hundred
thousand pounds so you know there's a
fair bit on the market for that sort of
thing the last three years
Bristol's core business has been
restoring their old cars an existing 6.6
liter engine but we just refurbished it
and rebuilt it this classic has been
given a second chance and now so as the
brand Bristol went bust in 2011 and was
rescued later that year by another UK
company Fraser Nash you know there was a
lot to do and we've kind of restructured
it yeah the biggest part of all that
that we were doing was in a building
reputation and that was you know there's
taking a lot of time to get the trust
back with the owners and all the guys
where all the business kind of drifted
away to other manufacturers millions of
pounds were invested by Fraser Nash a
specialist in electric hybrid technology
giving Bristol a new lease of life to
celebrate our Platinum anniversary in
the motor industry next year Bristol
cars will be launching a brand new model
will be an amazing car when this when
the car is revealed now you'll see the
styling cues of the previous models them
and it's not just in particular one
there are many Bristol cars in this in
these products but with with
cutting-edge technology from frozen
national project pinnacle will be the
first car from Bristol in 12 years will
it be enough though to relaunch the
brand